hanck going to make a housekeeping video
today how am I gonna make a funny
housekeeping video and yes I know I have
a lot of puffs for someone who got a
haircut ten days ago but the puffs alone
isn't funny enough people have seen the
puffs they know the puffs they're tired
of the puffs
I know Willy Peng today's video comes in
twelve parts odd parts housekeeping even
parts Willy
part one the winners of the advance
copies of Paper Towns from my punishment
last week are Megan users Rob from corn
well and Kelly 38 who by the way I think
has been watching us the entire 16
months so that's pretty cool and YouTube
users Julia X dark blue coffee and
Martina of Sweden man I hope Martina is
up like Sweden Ohio or else I'm gonna
pay a fortune in shipping costs send an
email to sparks lamp at gmail.com with
your address to claim your prize' part 2
Willie has a new trick hey Willie sit
yes good boy part 3 the nerd fighting
warming book club will be returning in
the near future please let us know in
comments what book you think we should
pick next part 4 it's one thing to enjoy
chewing shoes but Willie wants to
inhabit the shoe he wants to become the
shoe he wants his self to be annihilated
into the bright shining light of Souness
part 5 the 2008 Hank and John Green
great American tour de nerdfighting
featuring hopefully to Katherine and
occasionally the Yeti that's right
nerdfighters of America and hopefully a
couple places in Canada mark your
calendars for November because we
believe sorry sometimes I catch myself
in the viewfinder and I see my hair and
I crack up but the point is that we
believe that what happened in Grand
Rapids can happen everywhere and we're
going to go everywhere hopefully and
hopefully you'll come visit us by the
way if you're a librarian who'd be
interested in hosting slash sponsoring a
public event featuring us please email
spark slap at gmail.com I know I said
that fast but it's in textual form
either over here over here or down there
part six casts so Willie had to get a
new cast because he ate the last one
because he loves the taste of cast and
so then when they gave him his new cast
they put a heart on it a heart you can't
be the dread pirate fireball Wilson
Roberts with a heart on your cast anyway
I'm sure I'll eat through that cast in a
matter of days so hopefully next time
we'll get a skull and crossbones part 7
t-shirt design contest we are having one
do two part 5 email your t-shirt designs
to
is it getting old yet sparks laughs at
gmail.com the winners will receive some
seriously fabulous prizes that we will
not deliver to them for like six or
seven months sorry in advance god we are
bad at prize delivery we're like the
opposite of Ed McMahon part eight boy is
really cute when he's not peeing on
anything part nine I'm Nick ssin Airi
gosh a lot of interesting stuff is
happening at on dictionary.com where
nerdfighters are using the form of a
wiki wiki wiki to write a novel but
there also seems to be a strong desire
to have like an actual nerdfighter
encyclopedia which i think is a good
idea but it's not an idea from
dictionary in fact we used to have
something very much like that thanks to
the hard work of executive vice
president for nerd fighting in australia
stuart kid oh i'd love to see a
nerdfighter encyclopedia recreated if
you know how to make a wiki and can host
one please email
that's right sparks laugh at gmail.com
part 10 Lucky's a little wolf part 11
new challenge now nerdfighters says you
know there's a standing challenge that
if anyone can provide proof that Helen
Hunt has seen or heard the Helen Hunt
song then you can challenge us in any
way you see fit although our wives have
veto power miss hunt has so far proved
elusive but today I am announcing a
second celebrity related challenge the
other day I was looking on YouTube but
one of the most subscribed lists and I
saw this down there at the bottom on the
left that's us up there at the top Oprah
no Hank it's no secret that when it
comes to recruiting new nerdfighters
nerdfighter Ian's value quality over
quantity because we don't want to dilute
the awesome but Hank we are a mere six
thousand subscribers away from Pony
Oprah admittedly 6,000 subscribers is a
lot but still nerdfighters if and when
we pone Oprah you can challenge us in
any way you see fit it doesn't matter
how it happens I just want to state for
the record that pony Oprah would be the
greatest accomplishment of my life part
12 best wishes
he's like you woke me up from a nap to
hold me in front of a camera and say
best wishes and then I tried to explain
to him the best wishes joke but of
course he doesn't get it because he
hasn't seen all the videos yet because
he's still a baby